[Applause]
so obviously this familiar names in it
sort of you know han Solo and Chewbacca
but you guys are new so who are you
Amelia who use so I play Kira who am you
you're introduced to her very early on
in the in the story with growing up with
Han and then we're separated for
whatever reason and when you see her
again you're not really sure what's
happened in that time dun-dun-dun and
and so she's somewhat changed and then
they continue on together and in a
certain time trying not to do a spoiler
and I'm learning and learning and and so
it's this kind of you're on you're not
sure about who she is or why she's there
but you know that Han and her have a
connection a connection connection and a
mouth and a past and of ours do you have
a connection
I have many connections they dried and I
there she is
but you did rock up to work I mean that
yes you get is you yeah yeah they they
spent a lot of money removing me from
the film in a green suit underneath it
all and it was half a practical suit and
a half so you are sort of there I mean I
was yes yes yeah no one had a clue who I
was at the wrap party cuz I was like
who's the over mini ago that no one
recognized
[Music]
you